>> Greg: THE SNAKE.
YOU KNOW WHERE HE GOT THAT
NICKNAME.SNAKE THROUGH THE FIEL.
ALL RIGHT.
HERE'S MY QUESTION.
MAY NOT BE A QUESTION.
MAYBE IT'S AN OPINION.
IT SEEMS THAT WHAT THEY ARE
TRYING TO SHUT DOWN AS ANYTHING
THE KIND OF INDULGES THE
STRAIGHT MALE GAZE.
IT'S MORE LIKE ANYTHING THAT ARE
STRAIGHT GUYS ATTRACTED TO IS
KIND OF THE PROBLEM.
IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN WITH
CHEERLEADING IN GENERAL?
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE NEXT STEP
OR MAYBE IT ALREADY IS AND I'VE
MISSED IT.
>> Emily: IS ALREADY BEEN
HAPPENING.
THE WASHINGTON FOOTBALL TEAM
DISMANTLE THEIR CHEERLEADING
SQUAD.
THE ANSWER WAS, YOU FEEL MORE
TEMPTED BY THIS AND THERE ARE
ALLEGATIONS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
WOULD BE TO EXTINGUISH THE
TEMPTATION.
I THINK YOUR POINT ABOUT THIS
PLAYING INTO THE WOKE GODS
ESSENTIALLY TO PREVENT THEIR
BEING THE CULTURE MOB COMING OUT
OF THEM IS TOTALLY TRUE.
THERE ARE THREE COVERS.
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE ALL THE
BOXES ARE CHECKED.
THE TRANSGENDER POINT, NOT AN
ATHLETE BUT THEY ARE IN FACT A
MILLION TRANSGENDER ATHLETES OUT
THERE.
WE'VE BEEN SEEING THEM NOT ONLY
THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL SPORTS AND
THE SUBJECT OF A LOT OF
LEGISLATION BUT ALSO AT THE
OLYMPIC LEVEL.
THE FACT THAT THERE ARE GLOBAL
PARAMETERS SENT TO THAT RIGHT
NOW THAT THAT'S WHEN THEY'RE
GOING TO CHOOSE BECAUSE IT'S THE
SAFE PLAY.
THEY ARE NOT GETTING INTO THE
FRAY OF THE SPORTS WORLD.
>> Greg: WHY DIDN'T THEY
ACTUALLY GO WITH THE ATHLETE?
RIGHT?
>> THERE IS ONE REASON WHY.
>> Greg: I'LL TELL YOU WHY.
I SAID THIS BRIEFLY IN THE
MONOLOGUE, THE MOST PERVASIVE
DISCRIMINATION ON EARTH IS
SOMETHING WE ALL KNOW.
IT GOES BACK TO NATURAL
SELECTION.
ATTRACTION AND BEAUTY.
PEOPLE THAT ARE LUCKY TO
N
WITH CHEEKBONES GO MUCH FURTHER,